welcome to Wired's gadget challenge the
show where Eric and Justin from Battle
Damage test out the coolest products
ripped from the pages of Wired magazine
this week gifts with the coolest style
hey everyone I'm Justin I'm Eric and
today we're testing out three stylish li
designed gifts that's right we've got
the beautiful bluetooth gramophone the
brand-new bhalo stool and the super
powered dyson DC 34 vacuum the dyson DC
34 has some serious power it's sleek
lightweight ergonomic design and a max
mode setting makes this little vacuum a
lean mean clean machine her first
challenge we filled this kitty pool with
fruit flavored cereal whoever sucks more
than thirty seconds wins there's got to
be a better way to say
uses her Boca hello there's a coupon
oh I think I know who let's just measure
him players weigh-in okay
one pound nine point two ounces that's
abundance here you got two pounds one
ounce we have an official winner
you suck more congratulations the
stylish follow stool provides all the
therapeutic benefits of an exercise ball
but its style and good looks make sure
your home or office doesn't look like a
gym okay for this challenge we're gonna
see who can balance on the new bhalo
chair longer without their feet touching
the ground player ready go
I'm gonna stretch out first I didn't do
that
I'm really gonna get my core energized
player ready yeah two point five two
second Champions player attempting to
defeat own record next up is the
Bluetooth gramophone by Grandma Vox the
high quality steel horn is designed for
optimal sound and a dapper nostalgic
look it of course has bluetooth and
auxilary input in a battery that lasts
12 to 18 hours
that's it for this episode remember you
can learn more about all the products be
tested today by clicking the links in
the description below and make sure and
check out our other episodes including
our tour of the New York wired store for
more great guides and gifts the wired
store is opening this December so go
check it out and please subscribe